let's bring in our panel ben dominic
publisher of the federalist mar elias
and national political correspondent
of national public radio and jason riley
wall street journal columnist
senior fellow at the manhattan institute
also the author of the new book maverick
a biography of thomas soule jason let me
start with you
your thoughts about the biden speech
talk of mandates for vaccinations
on federal employees talks of
mandating masks and where we go from
here
well brett according to the cdc
uh something like 97 or more
of the people being hospitalized for
covet are unvaccinated
that sounds to me like the priority
should be vaccinating
people not getting people to go back to
masking
but what i think is really frustrating
the public here
is that we don't have any metrics we
don't what's the end game what's the
goal
what is the acceptable number uh rate of
hospitalization
or infection or covet deaths before we
return
back to normal and the problem is that
the the bureaucrats and politicians keep
moving the goal post we originally told
we didn't want to overwhelm our health
care system
have lines outside of hospitals well
even with that new variant
that's not what we're seeing so why are
we moving back in the direction of
lockdowns and masking
to your point someone who shares your
point of view admiral brett drawer used
to be on the task force
during the trump administration here's
what he said about the data we have
out in the public my major concern
is we had a incredibly important policy
announcement
by the cdc to recommend math scoring
even for those who are vaccinated
but they have supplied zero data no
transparency
no information why is that
because i don't i think they don't
really have the data or the data a week
dr wolinski said
in rare circumstances a vaccinated
person
may transmit well if it's one percent
point one percent
point zero one percent there's no reason
for the mask recommendations but we
don't know because they won't tell us
and we've invited the cdc director on
the show mar your thoughts about how the
president laid this out and
significant policy a potential policy
changes
yeah significant potential policy
changes the president wants
to get more people vaccinated that is
the one thing that we actually
know stops the spread of covet and the
problem is
that if you tell people they have to
mask
even if they're vaccinated in certain
places
in certain uh situations that's gonna
be a disincentive for people to get
vaccinated the
incentive for getting vaccinated is not
just a hundred dollars which is one of
the things that he's
was pushing today too it's also that you
get to live a life
kind of like pre-covid and if you still
have to wear a mask after you're
vaccinated i think that's going to
discourage people from getting the
vaccine which is the opposite of what
the white house wants
one thing he did say today ben and he
hasn't really focused on before
is giving credit to the republican
administration for getting this vaccine
up and running
and a democratic administration for
administrating it
administering it in all those arms
here's a look back what he said back in
september 2020 and what he said today
i trust vaccines i trust
scientists but i don't trust donald
trump
at this moment the american people can't
either scientific breakthroughs don't
care about calendars any more than the
virus does
they certainly don't adhere to election
cycles the vaccine was developed and
authorized
under a republican administration
and has been distributed and
administered under a democratic
administration
the vaccines are safe highly effective
there's nothing political about it
obviously in september it was as he was
warning about
rushing a vaccine before it was finished
ben
you know this i'm not going to take the
president at his word on this
because i don't believe that we ought to
at this point i don't believe this is
about
getting more people vaccinated the real
dearth of vaccinations as you know brett
are among those populations who are not
likely to be
listening to right wing charlatans or
anybody like that it's
black voters it's hispanic voters who
are unfortunately lagging behind
when it comes to their vaccination rates
what i heard
from the president today is a lot more
about politics than it is about
vaccination and that is a belief
on the part of leading democrats in
washington that the only way for them to
get their
their overall agenda pushed through
before a midterm that they believe
represents a tidal wave that will sweep
nancy pelosi
and others out of power is to lean into
the permanent pandemic
the emergency status of all of these
different things that will keep the
money flowing
and that will keep their policies at the
forefront
unfortunately i think they've made a
huge miscalculation with this
because i think americans are broadly
fed up with this type of approach to
things
they see the case counts they see the
death counts they can
see that when it comes to a city like
washington dc
you have a mask mandate right now that
has been reinstalled by
mayor muriel bowser for two and up
indoors and outdoors after a week in
which the seven day average of covet
deaths
was zero they do not believe that this
is about the facts on the ground anymore
they believe that it's about politics
and they are increasingly aware of this
as it comes to the
the process of getting back to school
public education and the teachers unions
sounding more and more notes that sound
like you're going to have another year
of remote learning
if you live in a state run by a
democratic governor
that's a big charge ben the president
saying that it's about saving lives and
telling stories about obviously people
uh in the hospital fighting and
eventually dying saying doc can i get
the vaccine now
uh telling emotional stories and and
trying to get people
uh into taking the vaccine jason
is the mandate part of that on the
federal government for
he said he wants the pentagon to look
into mandating all service members and
and federal employees it's already in
the department of veteran affairs
as far as a mandate for vaccines what do
you think that is going to lead to
and is it going to get broader that
mandate
i think it will get broader i don't
think it will be helpful i don't i don't
think that people who are hesitant to
get the vaccine
are going to respond the way the
administration is hoping
to to these mandates we're going to get
some early tests
of this political test of this i'm
thinking particularly of the recall
election going on
out in california in september where the
governor there gavin newsom
has been very very careful in his
approach
to handling this and returning back to
to mandates and masking and so forth
because he's worried about a political
backlash
so i think that could be an early test
of how uh you know a large
electorate as the california is response
to this sort of thing speaking of
california just in the past few minutes
the los angeles unified school district
has said it will require all students
and employees who are returning for
in-person instruction
to participate in weekly covit 19
testing regardless
of vaccination status uh just announced
that
mara and to your point it's a little
frustrating for parents and and but
they're going to do what they're going
to do
to get kids back in school right they're
talking about having in-person learning
and they're talking about
testing and um i don't know if we've had
a huge backlash against testing but that
certainly is an alternative to
vaccination if you don't want your kid
to be vaccinated or if your kid can't be
vaccinated
they can be tested parents want their
kids to be safe they want to know if a
teacher in their school
has covid i mean you know that's an
alternative and that's
actually the alternative to virtual
learning
uh so i don't know if that's going to be
uh become
a kind of political flashpoint or not
but it seems to me
that most parents would would want that
information well just to be clear this
is if you're vaccinated or not
vaccinated you're going to get tested
every week in l.a right and i think
there are real questions about what the
teachers union is going to say and do
to ben's point in coming weeks we're
going to talk more about what the house
is doing about the mask mandate a little
bit later